now if you are looking to buy a new home
here in the valley it may not be the
easiest thing to do
yeah we keep hearing that a new home
construction is also in really high
demand
joe mohler is live at rainbow and
russell with more on some of the
challenges that builders are facing
joe well if you are looking to buy a
home you could be waiting a little while
according to homebuilders research
numbers the median price of a new home
last month was around
380 000 experts say there are a number
of reasons why new home prices are
going up at the end of april we'll have
a house
greg renfro will soon close on a new
centennial hills home in this kb homes
neighborhood
i see a lot of people inside their sales
office looking through the models trying
to find their house
after having a tough time finding a
resale home he chose to build a new one
right after he locked in his lot in the
fall he says the demand got a little
crazy
i was there yesterday to faxing over
some finalized paperwork for our
mortgage people our lender and
she had mentioned that there is a pretty
huge wait list
that they're doing an actual drawing for
the people
waiting lists are becoming common in
april of 2020 at the beginning of the
pandemic there were about 60 new homes
selling a week
so far in 2021 the average is 331 per
week
let's not forget the demand from our
west coast state california
they're flocking here in droves and uh
you know i mean it's good but also
there's not enough to go around
southern nevada home builders
association ceo nat hodgson's estimates
at least half of the people buying
are coming from california and i'd say
our over overall number right now
is 50 percent in some communities i've
heard them reporting as much as
80 percent a shortage of appliances and
lumber is causing prices to go up
over the last 10 months he says the cost
of lumber is up 215
that's unreal that could mean anywhere
between 24
000 and 35 000 of increase
hodgson says he is optimistic the market
will continue to do well
quite honestly we can't build a single
more house than we're building today
now back out here live hodgins also says
there isn't one particular neighborhood
or
area of the valley that's selling
quicker or more than the other and he
says
buyers are just going to the
neighborhoods where they can get in the
homes the quickest
reporting las vegas joe mohler 8 news
now